foreign
now there's a lot of tweets that make me
angry and there's a lot of tweets that
make me laugh this one somehow did both
and so I wanted to share it with you
Jade and all of our listeners out there
and get your take on it so uh boys throw
up that tweet
so this is a tweet from someone that
says
finally paid off my vodka crayon from
last month God is good with a little
praise emoji and it's a receipt from
afterpay they put a 12 cocktail on
payments for easy payments on a 12
cocktail no no no and not God is good
don't throw God he had nothing to do
with it this is your stupidity oh Lord
don't blame him don't thank him
this is crazy and and it's after pay I I
could tell it's after pay based on the
logo I know these scumbers I I I'm sure
so this is if you all don't know the
this is the new thing that gen Z's into
which is buy now pay later so they're
anti-credit cards but they're Pro
payments because they're going well
there's no interest so how bad can it be
it's bad payments on a drink because
think about it that's one interaction
that's one time going out you keep
adding that to your tab with your
payments and all of a sudden you go okay
well I only spent 25 of what I would
have spent which leaves room in my
budget so that I can pay after pay the
next month and the next month and the
next month let me kind of insane if you
I'm just gonna say if you have to put a
12 drink on payments you are a hot flame
of a flame of a mess
you're just a Hot Flaming funky mess
it's it's gotten real bad out there Jade
and these companies you've heard of them
after Pay Here's their tagline get what
you want we've got your back okay that's
that's a great way to create an entire
generation that's broke wow here's the
firms pay at your own pace that's with
hey hey pay at your own pace no rush
we're happy to wait we'll take another
payment next month and then Clarin is my
favorite
get financial breathing room because
nothing says breathing room like being
chained what
oh my goodness and here's what gets me
clarna also brags to the retailers that
use this program
that the consumer will spend up to 45
percent more if you have klarna as an
option
they know what they're doing well duh
that's why they make billions of dollars
and you remain broke but instead you go
no Jade it's smart I'm I'm leaving room
in my budget Jade what do you mean I I
can't even breathe right now George I
can't even breathe you need to use klona
because they'll give you some breathing
around apparently oh okay and they'll
give me a drink while I'm at it vodka
cran look I read a stat that said 57 of
people who use buy now pay later
regretted
their purchase buy now regret later
that's the new name how about just buy
now pay now that feels like the way God
and grandma would do it hot diggity
we're gonna bring God into this yeah
it's insane to me what if you just
popped out a ten dollar bill in a single
two singles and just pay for that 12
drink
like I mean blowing my mind oh God just
make your drinks at home people you know
do it like we doing smart money happy
hour okay we're on a budget out here
we're not going to these crazy cocktail
bars and by the way it's just what it's
all watered down it tastes gross yeah
it's just done going out I'm too I'm
like an old curmudgeon of a man jade
look you're telling me Nashville
cocktails are now 20 bucks and they have
a liquor tax of an extra 15 on top of
the 10 in Nashville and I'm like I'm
just done you know I'm going to the crib
I'm going to the crib I'ma pour my Eagle
Rare and my in my in my glass with my
Square Cube because I'm not going to one
of these restaurants trust and believe
I'm not going to Applebee's getting an
old fashioned where there's like 0.00
of drink in the drink you know what I'm
saying I'll stick to my water that's
what I eat when I when I go out I get
water because I'm too cheap and I have
money I just I'm like this ain't worth
it it's not worth not paying the
premiums it never well I'm not paying in
four payments exactly goodness